I was able to customize my cloud code
into a cloud designer which allows me to
iterate UI 10 times faster in cursor and
wings serve directly forking and
generating five to even 10 different UIs
at the same time and all this are made
possible with some hidden clock code
feature like parallel task commands and
new SDK that they just introduced. I'll
break it down for you so you can
replicate on your end. So one thing I
think people didn't realize is that you
can actually spin up multiple sub agents
within cloud code by simply prompiting.
For example, I can give a simple prompt.
Start a three parallel agent to
implement variations of the to-do app
UI. And then you will see that it start
three different task that is happening
at the same time. One agent will be
doing minimalist to-do UI. Another will
be doing modern to-do and third will be
cambban UI. And boom, you just got three
totally different style at the same
time. So it'll be much faster for you to
iterate. And you can imagine we can
actually package this to be some really
interesting UI iteration process with
this parallel task capability. There was
actually pretty heated debate last week
on Twitter where dev team published a
blog post called don't build multi- aent
system. One of the key insights they got
is that for task like coding where each
action you take actually imply specific
set of decisions you make and when you
do parallel task it is very likely leads
to things like merge conflicts because
each sub agent has no context about what
the other agent is working on and the
best approach they found is actually
just don't do parallel task at all and
putting everything into one single
thread. However, a few days later,
Entropy released their own blog post
about how do they apply multi- aent in
their own research system where they
build this group of agents and each sub
agent can actually have parallel task to
do things like research and I think both
had pretty valid points because most of
the time you do want to making sure the
agent has a full context when execute
task but there are scenario that makes
sense like research it is going to be
faster if you spin up five research
topics and summarize everything in the
end and same thing for the UI design
paralas is actually perfect use case
because When we do design in Figma, what
we often do is that we'll just fork and
do a few different variations and
compare them kind of side by side and
eventually we get like final version. So
have that capability of have parallel
task on design has been a pretty good
pattern and what I want to show you is
how I utilize the parallel task
capability in cloud code to have some
really interesting UI workflow. But
before I dive into that, I know many of
you are building AI applications or AI
agents that needs access to internet
data from research about business to get
latest news and a smart and reliable way
to turn any website data into large
language model friendly format is
critical. That's why I want to introduce
you to FRO. They were the first open-
source project. They offer effective way
to turn any website into clean format
that is optimized for large language
model to consume. You can browse through
all the subpage of a website and it
handle PDF, word doc or even Excel file
that are attached from URL and has
capability like smart weight d content
loading so that you can guess website
with more strict anti-bos setup and for
the past few months they just launched a
whole bunch of new feature that is going
to make web scraping 10x easier. For
example, they introduced this new search
endpoint that's going to give you back
the most random websites as well as
extract markdown content of those
website directly in just one API call.
This is going to make your AI
application way faster because you don't
need scarfolding the whole pipeline of
search and scrape from different
service. And they also introduced this
new extract endpoint where it can handle
things like pageionation and page
interaction with their own fire one
agent that is capable to interact with
website like e-commerce to clicks
through buttons get a full content and
it can even similar complex action like
login and authentication as well. All
you need is just give a URL, the prompt,
the data structure you want and this
agent will open up the browser, navigate
through the website to multiple
different pages until they find
information you want. And most
importantly, those abilities can be
called from API endpoint directly. So
you can give your own agents internet
and research capability with just few
lines code or integrate to automation
platform like Zapier and relevance AI by
calling firecore API directly. So if
you're looking for a smart way to script
internet data, I highly recommend you go
and check out firecro. Now let's get
back how can you customize cloud code
into cloud designer. So to understand
the workflow I'm going to show you there
are four core concepts. We already
covered the sub aents part and second
one is cloud.md. If you're pretty
familiar with cursor is basically cursor
rules but for cloud code with this one
we can customize how cloud code should
work and give it knowledge about what
type of task you should do in parallel
what type of task you shouldn't. And I
will show you a quick example. For
example, if you open cloud in any folder
and just create a file called cloud.md
and you can just put whatever
instruction here like you always respond
in all caps. Now if you try to run cloud
and say hi, it will respond back in all
caps. But you can imagine we can also
put some very specialized prompt for
this as well. For example, this is a
prompt that I have been playing with
internal UI design where it includes
things like the color, font, layout,
stuff like that. So I can put in this
and also adding maybe some special rules
that when you were asked to build UI
iterations, you always just create one
single HTML file. So I can give a simple
prompt like build me a modern to-do app
UI. It will basically following my
rules. It won't create some complicated
project. And this will just create a one
single HTML file that contain a nice
kind of modern UI. So this is cloud MD
the custom rules for cloud code. The
next thing which is very powerful called
commands. So you can basically predefine
list of common workflow that you want
cloud to follow. So you can create a
folder called cloud. Inside you can have
another folder called commands. This is
where we're going to create some cool
stuff. Let's say you want to create a
joke generated command. So you create a
joke.md and we can just say make a joke
about arguments. So arguments is a
special thing that pass to clock in the
command so that you almost create a
prompt template that can be used for
many different scenarios and I can give
it some custom instruction always and a
joke with a man eating chips and now if
I do slash you will see that there's a
slash joke option and I will just type
in joke then what are you putting down
after is what's going to be passed to
arguments so I here can say AI coding
and then you will see that I generate a
prompt about AI coding and with the
specific instruction that we give inside
here if from cloud code's official doc.
It can even do something like you can
literally just natural language putting
some commands that you wanted to run. It
will actually execute those command line
before I do the task. For example, you
can actually create a command like this
where it will do those command line to
check get status first before you
execute a task. So if I try this and do
the joke now it is actually running
those command line to check the get
status because I didn't set up yet. It's
just a not a get repository. But if I
initiate the git here and run cloud
again, it will give you a different joke
about main branch because now I set up
the git. So to me this is like a mystery
but super super powerful feature. And
what I want to show you is how do I use
this to create some sort of UI flow. So
I'll create another folder inside let's
say UI and create a one called extracted
system and putting this prompt.
Basically it will have the task of the
UI it should analyze which we're passing
through a image URL and the goal here is
to extract like color pattern typography
stuff like that and also save the design
system JSON into a folder called prd. So
this will allow us to give cloud code a
kind of UI mock and it will just
generate the design system from that. I
found that this works much better than
you just give the UI reference ask to do
right away. And second command I also
use is this iterate design MD. So this
is the one that I want cloud to spin up
three or five sub aents to concurrently
implement the same UI in different
style. So I will ask it to analyze a
design system JSON file we created and
then build one single HTML page and
output the HTML in the UI iteration
folder called UI 1 UI2 UI3. So with
these two things I'm going to show you a
very interesting workflow. First I will
go to website like moen or dribble to
just get some UI inspiration. And let's
say I quite like this one. I can save
this image zui/ extract design system
and I will drag this image here and then
it will create this design system.json
this prd folder as I instructed which
have those kind of more detailed style.
Next I can call second command iterate
design give a prompt a modern phone
to-do app using this design style as
reference which I'm referring to this
design system file we created earlier.
Then it will set up three different
tasks. You can see for each task it
actually has a very detailed task about
UI reference design directions like
that. By the way, you can use control R
to expand and then Ctrl E to see those
details. And of course, you can like
always toggle between. But honestly,
there's still some bugs. So, I'm just
going to let it run like this. And now
it output three different UI in the UI
iterations. If I open them, they all
looks somewhat different in terms of
style and animations. And what's really
cool is that let's assume I like this
UI2 version. But I want to iterate a bit
further based on this version because I
want to build a kind of dark mode and
then I can do the same thing again. This
iterate UI2 HTML version which is best
one so far and try dark mode. Then you
will see this time it will analyze the
current UI2 design and try to spin up
three parallel tasks. And the more I use
it, I realized that the way this command
line works, it's basically sending a
prompt template to the cloud and along
with this prompt you put in here. And
this is really interesting, right?
Because traditionally, if you design
software, you probably were uh designing
a way that you have to define what type
of arguments are and user have to give
those arguments. But they basically keep
it super free. Uh you just give a free
text agent just magically figure out.
This is just such interesting kind of
design pattern I found. So after 200
seconds, I got three versions of
different UI based on the previous
version two I like, but some sort of
variation between each one of them. Like
this one has some kind of glowy uh
style, which is pretty cool. But this is
kind of the workflow. I can choose the
version I like and then ask to iterate a
few different versions. I can even
probably grab the glowy style from this
version as well as a pure dark
background from this style. Ask it to
iterate. I'm pretty sure it can figure
out. And once you done, you can get a
HTML that has a style you want. then
just start prompting cursor to actually
break down into components and build a
proper UI in nextJS project. But this
workflow of iterating UI is something
that I've been trying a lot and it has
been really really helpful. But this
workflow can only allow you to build
like single HTML page. What if you want
to set up parallel agent to work on
different UI iteration on your actual
production NexJS app and this is where
the fourth concept comes in Git work
tree. So if you're familiar with g most
of the time you can only have one branch
running on your computer at the same
time and g work tree is a feature they
have that allow you to set up multiple
different sandbox environment of your
specific report. So you can get a
multiple cloud code each working on a
individual work tree without impact each
other's work and in the end you can just
pick up the version you like and merge
them together and all you need to do
just run this command get work tree
add-b with a branch name and then pass
where do you want to copy and create a
sandbox of your current rip for example
here I have a basic to-do app that I
built with nextjs and chass in it has
multiple different components it is much
more complicated than a single HTML page
what I can do is open terminal and do
get work tree add b which is branch name
and I'll call it like demo branch. Then
I'll remove that into a specific folder.
Um what I going to do is I will just
create a trees folder with the same
branch name so it's easier for us to
identify and understand what that is
about. If I do this you can see a new
folder called trees created. Inside it
has another folder called demo branch
which has everything we have at root
branch. So this is how you can set up a
work tree. And now I can do cd trees
demo branch. And once I get inside, I
can do PNPM install and PMP dev. And you
will see the same application is running
here in a different portal. And the
easiest way will be we can just set up a
new cloud here and ask it to iterate UI.
And once you get one version you're
pretty happy with, you can set it up and
do get merge demo branch. So this how
the work tree works. Theoretically, you
can already have a workflow to firstly
create multiple different work trees and
then set up parallel agents to work on
each individual work tree folders. But
what I really experimented is I actually
created one command called execute
parallel agents and this is one command
with the prompt template that I have. It
will have two steps. First step will be
set up multiple different g trees based
on the user's request. If a user asks
for three different variations then
create three different work trees and
each one of them follow the naming
convention we have and then do pmppm
install setup. Then step two is set up
parallel sub agents. This is where the
master cloud code agent will spin up
multiple different sub agents. Each one
work on a different branch and this
command will basically do the whole
workflow for us. Whenever I want
multiple different agents to iterate
this UI on existing production projects.
For the second prompt here, I actually
got some inspiration from another
content creator called indie dam den who
also talk about this parallel agent
workflow. So I highly recommend you
check out if you want to learn more. But
let me quickly show you how does this
work. So I have this command that I
showed you earlier and just do cloud
then I can just slash to use execute
parallel agent command and I'll just
give a command try three versions of UI
one nerdy style one kid style and one
gaming style. There we say I will help
you create three parallel agents work on
different things with three different
to-dos. Firstly it will create three
work trees for nerdy kit and gaming UI
style. Install dependencies in each work
tree and then launch three parallel
agents to work on each one of them. And
now if I open trees you can see there
are three different branch and work tree
has been created and after that it will
start setting up the project. And after
setup it's going to launch three
parallel agent to implement different UI
stuff. And you can see three parallel
task has been created. Each one of them
going to be assigned to a individual sub
agent. And if we do control R you can
see the detail of each task that sub
agent is receiving. It has the task the
prompt the key files to modify and
requirements and each task is slightly
different to reflect style we want. And
this process is going to take some time.
I've actually found this is slower than
I just call let's say three entropic
call in parallel. I assume entropy
actually do some kind of re limiting
management. So it does take some time
but the cool thing is that you get all
those UI in one go. So you don't have to
follow that specific linear flow and
each version will be inside its own
folder. So in the end I got three
different versions. Each one of the
version does look quite different based
on the kind of style of prompt it
explore like this nerdy dad version this
kind of kids version and we also have
this kind of gaming style as well. And
you can imagine I can even further doing
this. Assuming I like this nerdy
version, then I can give another
parallel task to set up three more new
branches to iterate based on this. So
this is kind of the workflow I feel like
going to be really developed for next
few months especially for UI iteration
tasks. But in the end just making sure
remember to delete the trees that you
don't want because each branch actually
can be pretty big because you need to
install all the packages inside.
Meanwhile, I was imagined what if we
have this kind of parallel task
execution experience plus some sort of
easy way for you to set up sandbox, view
the results, iterate based on certain
design and also delete the work tree
when it's not needed. Especially now
cloud code has its SDK where we can
integrate a coding assistant very easily
with custom prompt tools. So during the
weekend, my friend Jack and I have been
trying this weekend purchase. We
basically integrate to cloud AI SDK and
build a cursor extension that you can
inside your existing pure right away and
ask it to start experimenting different
UI. You will have Canva on the right
side to preview the UI generated. Then
select certain version you like and ask
it iterated further. So you can visit
superdesign.dev and click on install for
free button. This will allow you to just
one click installing cursor when you
serve or any other ID you're using. It
will open the superdesign extension and
after install you can do command shiftp
and this one option called configure
entropy API key. So you put your entropy
API key here because we are using cloud
code SDK behind the scenes and once that
part is done click on super design. This
will open a chat on the left side and a
camera view on the right side and you
can give a prompt design me some
wireframe of a calculator. Then you will
see the agents start working and trigger
multiple tasks. Each task with a
slightly different uh brief about what
type of design it is. You're basically
creating design inside the super design
design iteration folder. And at this
point each design takes roughly 1 minute
to generate. They're very clear path for
us to optimize and make it way faster.
Uh but we just want to ship it as the
first version for now. And all the
design generated will be showing up on
the right side. And now you can see
generate a few different kind of
wireframe options for the calculator.
And once I find the version I prefer, I
can click on this which will have a few
different options either create a
variations or iterate feedback as well
as copy prompt for cursor we insert
direct with. So I can click on this
iterator with feedback button. Then give
a prompt. This looks great. Now build a
hi-fi mo based on this layout. Then you
will see here it generate a few high
fidelity mockups based on that specific
layout. And you can imagine we can keep
iterating giving feedback and once I'm
happy I can click on this copy prompt
button. This will copy the full style.
So you can pass to cursor or cloud code
to do the actual implementation of the
web app. So this is the first version we
spin up going to do a lot of
improvements but super keen to just hear
feedback. Is this something you find
useful? If so, please give it a try.
This will be open source project you can
just download and try out yourself. So I
will put the link in the description
below so you can go and try out.
Meanwhile, I will put all the problems I
shared in AI builder club, which is a
community I'm building that has top AI
builders who are launching AI products.
Myself and other people will share also
tips and workflows that we found really
useful for both AI coding and build
large modelic software. So, I've also
put a link in the description below for
you to join as well if you want to learn
more. I'm really excited about this
project and what kind of feedback you
guys have. This is just a v 0.01 version
that only created one single HTML page.
The next version, we're going to add the
default work tree support so you can
iterate UI of your existing production
application. I'll keep you updated.
Thank you and I see you next time.